who have been the people that you've met
when you uh achieved this level where
you go into these premieres you're going
these places and there's an actor that
you idolized and they look at you and
they're excited to see you when they
come over do you have does anyone who
pops for you where you think oh my god
well they have Conan O'Brien uh
and it's always a big moment okay that's
the p
the Gods stuff now talking about humans
I will say Al Pacino yes
he called me after watching before night
falls but it was two o'clock in the
morning in Spain and it was a time where
there was a tape uh uh an answering
machine with tape remember so I was
sleeping I was like who's calling and
then hi hi
[Laughter]
and I couldn't get the phone like
Albertson is calling my home I saw the
movie I like that a lot and
congratulations I was like and then I
went and I played and I play it again
and I play it again and I have the tape
I have the tape yeah so the first day I
met him in Toronto Film Festival I went
to the to the to the toilet and I took a
picture with a camera no phones at the
time
of my my face in the mirror because my
face was like I'm going to meet Al
Pacino and the good thing about it all
is that he's he's such a wonderful man
yes yeah so when you meet someone that
you admire so much you go and he's even
better uh that you would imagine yeah he
uh my first encounter with him because I
you know grew up on The Godfather movies
and then Serpico and it just you know
Dog Day Afternoon and it's just I mean
he's
he is such a above a star to me he's
something else and so I was working on
an award show uh in here in in the
states and I think I was in LA and I did
my thing when I write and then I go
backstage and it's between it's in a
commercial break so I go back stage and
suddenly all they're bringing all this
scenery through they say clear the way
clear the way so I get pushed into this
little room literally pushed into a
little room
side room to make way for these guys to
come through and I look around and it's
just a room with me a tiny room like the
size of a phone booth and it's me and Al
Pacino
and I'm dumb struck and he goes
and liquid just comes out of oh God
I urinated it
was awful like it came out of every pore
and I went Miss Pacino you have no idea
and I just tell him how much he makes me
music and then he puts it back on me no
you a tightrope every knife a new script
you got a wing it Madness you know and
he's just going on about how oh sure
I've done the Godfather
but I saw you with Al Roku you know and
he was Liquid himself yeah no
he wasn't but I thought this is now sir
no sir and I just blew my mind and then
every now and then I'll be in New York
in a restaurant and it just happened
recently where I hear Conan and it's and
he's there in the corner in a restaurant
and uh and I get to have these little
conversations with him and what I found
is in the last one I'm so self-conscious
about
taking up his time that'll have a few
back and forth with things with him the
other and then I'll say like well you
know have a great meal one it's nice to
see you when I run away and then he
apparently because I ran to this woman
who was at the table a couple days later
coincidentally at this other event and
she said I was like why did he run away
I ran away because I'm scared oh you're
Al Pacino I don't want to wish he's fled
he flew where did he go but uh yeah that
would be one I would think
he's just a guy that uh and I read
somewhere and this is something that I
completely agree with because I'm on
record as saying this a long time ago
but you were Starstruck and had a bit of
a man crush on Brad Pitt oh yeah who
doesn't thank you of course because
there are many times where women have
said to me about men don't you think
he's attractive and I'm like I just I I
don't know I don't you know it doesn't
but Brad Pitt I think damn yeah I sleep
with that guy of course I don't even
know how it works but I would what I do
as I was told that's Brad Pitt
I'd have someone explain to me what my
role is in this
my top of my down below am I against the
I don't care it doesn't matter somebody
told me just do it do it a series of
drawings a diagram but I mean it really
is like a real charismatic and good
looking and I don't know I agree with
that so maybe the three of us we have
something
and then when she says like you know
what I really love you Javier and yes
you and I should uh get together that's
when you have to say no there's one
person I want to bring along and Brad's
probably like oh well it's you know I
don't know I guess it's another huge
yeah you know it's like it's Tom Cruise
or it's Ben Affleck like no no
[Laughter]
oh gosh
it's happening it's happening he doesn't
know yet but it's happening oh boy when
is this when does this come out does
this come out soon this comes out on
Brad Pitt threesome day
guys I'm I I'm here to promote a movie
up for kids okay let's bring this up hey
when I when he said threesome he meant
Bicycle Built for three that's right a
ride to the park and then we all eat
sandwiches three men and a little baby
exactly exactly exactly